[Music]
here's a question for you if a xylophone
plays in a forest and there's no one to
hear it does it make a sound yes yes it
does created by Morihiro hara no in
japan this woodland xylophone plays by
itself but how the biggest constant they
have working with this dial phone that's
going through the forest is basically
gravity they have this ball and they
know the ball is gonna roll down the
hill and what they're doing is using the
force of this ball and as it drops on
each key or each step it's gonna play a
tone as long as that slope is at a good
angle it'll continue to play so how does
one tiny ball make such beautiful music
to change the tempo what you would do is
change the slope of the angle the faster
the song the higher the incline and the
slower the song the less steep the
incline
so once you get the tempo right which
they do by using gravity now all they
have to do is create different notes
which they do by changing the shape so
that when the ball hits the step then
that wood will vibrate at a different
frequency thus creating different
pitches they've kept the width and the
depth very consistent and just changed
the length in order to to tune each key
but there's actually a ton of thought
and a ton of mathematics that has gone
into it to actually tune it just right
this is beautiful